welcome to this video playing a 15
minute game against max power from
Denmark I've played him recently I think
I won the game but I don't remember
really how it went down what game was
that let me just check this he does not
I'm just curious let me check my own
history I would've been played him
recently it was with black game with
black I cannot examine a game while I
play let us make some sense actually
okay so this was a blumenfeld gambit
yeah I remember this was this crazy
Blumenfeld gambit game okay so here we
got a sloth defense i played the queen
bee three line a line that i can
recommend to white players it's not this
is this line it is not some miracle
weapon that will win you all games but
it has one very important point it's not
a very theoretically intense line and
you still can get a little bit of
something here and there so on it's a
good practical choice not needing much
time to prepare and so you can do
something very often the trade office
you play em and less work heavy opening
repertoire very often you have the
problem that you get very often stale
positions or position that really you
don't allow for much active play or you
get positioned that are active but I bet
there's this very often the thing that
is happening so it's very it's very
difficult at times to
find opening lines that sort of offer a
good balance between still being able to
do a bit of something and put some
pressure here and there but so not
demanding so much of a workload and this
if you look for a line again the Slav
this is quite a good choice i believe
the screen be through your queen situ he
is very very similar okay let's see what
he's doing this III Queenie to this is a
prophylactic approach the Queen on c4
has sometimes exposed to moves like b5
and c5 and I basically go away from the
center before those moves can even hit
me if he go see five now for example
white can play rook do you want it after
the capture tape with the night opening
up the diagonal this is in fact black
some general issue that he needs to
address my bishop on g2 can very often
become a very strong piece very much
comparable to the Catalan if black plays
see 5 or 5 45 not so much but c5 at the
at the wrong moment yeah this is very
often a good idea pushing the ape on the
idea being to play Queen B 6 a-6 ok
Knight c3 he may be placed 94 hmm which
is not terribly grateful black but if he
gets to exchange some material it's
probably here probably helpful so I'm
not going to do this right away you know
he might go for Queen asics really but I
don't turn lead to a trade of course I
can move the Queen I wonder
92 94 I didn't I didn't I actually had
this recently in a game night if for
knight takes Bishop takes 95 Bishop g2
97 this idea i think i had this and it
Nets me the bishop out right yep I had
this I think in a game against Richard
Jones wasn't it another 15 minute game a
while ago I had this this exact position
on this particular motif okay while it
is nice to have gained the bishop pair
here it does not mean and winning the
game automatically because black is
still having an absolutely solid
structure which is quite difficult to to
break down so it's far too early to to
celebrate things happen okay we can
still play maybe five at the right
moment c5 will always work always open
up the long diagonal this is not to look
right to me champ how to place pieces
here he might play a form
yeah probably need to retreat this
anyway because it can always be hit by
nine f6 or something and i'm not i'm not
sure yet right you how to set up my
other pieces Bishop like the bishop like
a move like a bit should be two for
example he might simply answer with
bishop before and if we trade dark
square Bishop it's dark squared bishop
it's pretty much clear that I don't
don't have anything i wonder if i should
actually what about efore here by the
way if for Bishop e3 e4 Bishop f6b
should be three that's not bad and then
come on if he plays Queen a six I
probably play Quincy to avoiding the
trade and this basically renders Queen
a6 useless or at least really not not
having much point Bishop are interesting
this ad didn't really expect no but it's
not not bad
yeah but play d5 my bishop is in danger
of becoming a somewhat somewhat bad
piece very interesting so I probably
should take it right takes Knight takes
and then Bishop somewhere Bishop f4
probably here Bishop e3 there is just
Bishop c5 this does not help at all yeah
it's still very very solid position for
blood here here it can yeah yeah this is
a possibility or Bishop f6 was also was
also also possible yeah very tough now
to avoid further trades yep
yeah we did this this configuration
Queen Queen and night against Queen and
Bishop which notoriously which
notoriously is said to be good for Queen
and Queen at night there is some point
to that it's not it's not a complete
complete fairy tale this this this this
thing but still here there are also
rooks on the board and and [ __ ] I'm a
bit quicker in terms of the D file note
that in an end game without heavy pieces
just bishop against night would be quite
nice for white as something like f for
gaining space and then bishop h3c 8
activating the bishop this would be very
nice for why at this end game so when
black black must be careful with with
trading okay the night is aiming for
those squares should I go to age three
yeah I can play this first actually it's
no reason not to
I thought that age 394 Queen III would
be very nice now isn't that good okay
you can no I cannot remove the bishop I
cannot win with the night okay now no
use in spending much more time here this
looks like the right move anyway so 94
Queen III should just win it i think now
g5 i take d 8 so i actually expect him
to take on d to rook takes Queen takes
rook to e8 the screen d8 winning we
takes Queen takes Knight g5 okay I just
drop back to g2 and I still control the
default on let's just just it's just a
position that is slightly better for
white there is no no way around that
really okay I can take here now mm I can
take if we can take with the f porn of
course and not even not just can he must
take with the earth porn f pawn I Quincy
for our curtis's of course better for
white but how much better is it
always tough this decision should you
take here or is this setting off for too
little not easy
what if i take there and play Queen h5
intending Queen to e5 and enter taking a
five okay let's do that a lot I'm not
really sure maybe it should be six is
just terrible positionally but it it
felt interesting if it takes on d to now
plays rock d8 I can take on a five this
is important and the idea the general
idea is to yeah rook to e8 as Queen 85
this can be easily missed because it's
such a long queen but before I do that
let me quickly check but i know i think
i can read just take it those long Queen
moves can be very easily missed so I've
one upon which is very very nice is it
winning though hmm is it winning
how to play it going to see fire would
be very nice maybe like that and then
Quincy for covering here from the side
and preparing to to gain gain space I
can also go to f5 now this is also a
good square and this is all these kind
of moves it's also quite nice if I go
here and then Queen III to g5 it should
be a very nice position from the Queen
black can never trade and this should be
a big problem maybe he needs to do
something like win before trying to get
some activity going okay this is
actually similar if i go here queen
deform
I can go here though this is quite
interesting attacking b7 with a check so
we cannot really i think he must go back
now to d7 or sm exactly and now he's
somewhat tied down maybe this even
Quincy five coming yeah Quincy fire I
cannot ever take it and ok he cannot go
here as this false with check so I can
even improve a bit further here on the
queenside mmm this
I'll go here how does he actually ran
after the capture Queen takes how does
he protect the beep on and deep okay
that was actually not good I can give
the check here by the way check yeah I
can give the check i think i can trade
really a beacon he can go there but i
have a quick f5 i have a cook f5 yeah
let's Jesus a win death to the f porn is
winning now isn't it don't tell me this
is not winning a this would be strange
okay
okay I can't even go g4 here right was
not necessary not really I think this is
the easiest he's running out of moves
now f6 check black resigns yeah he just
blundered a poor nine there was always
some some pressure on blacks position
but yeah very crucial point here I'm not
sure if I should take really it's of
course a trade-off in the in the purest
sense of the word because while my
bishop the bishop is stronger than the
night that that's clear but should I
take it anyway here there is maybe a
spot where it makes sense because his
pawn structure is severely compromised
Quincy for was the alternative but I
like this idea getting the Queen here
and it said it said this little trap
which she fell right into it can really
easily happen that you overlook those
long Queen moves and yeah this is
probably a winning this end game it's
just very young uncomfortable for black
check your Queenie sameness is losing so
sure but there really was no big
alternative if you if you go somewhere
here I know I just take him cannot
cannot cannot cannot hold this really
check yet here this multi winning king
and corn and gaming in various ways yeah
interesting so here absolutely must
avoid to to blunder to blunder the porn
'if is maybe a moose
what about Queen f5 here intending look
ahead and queen here maybe in the screen
of six ER or queen here yeah of course
the computer is an excellent defender in
this in this position yeah well white
has to pawn islands black has three it
is a very slight edge for white maybe
not something that should often win but
it is a slight pool pretty much clear
also cater the palm plunder is probably
losing so he really needed to play a 5v5
sorry it's also very logical move
blocking the Queen on the fifth ok I
hope you enjoyed it thanks for watching